what is either what what is this
International nuclear fusion Mega
project uh being built in this in the
south of France so it's scientific
purpose is a worthy one then it's
essentially an any Fusion device
the thing that you want to see is more
and more relative amounts of
self-heating and this is something that
had not been seen although although we
have made Fusion reactions and we'd seen
small amounts of the self-heating we
never got to a dominant this actually
goes to this QP business okay the goal
of eater and it shifted around a little
bit historically but very you know
fairly quickly became we want to get to
a large amount of self-heating so this
is why it has a its primary feature is
to get to QP of around 10 and through
this this is a way to study this plasma
that has more higher levels of
self-determination around on it
but it also has another feature which
was let's produce fusion power at a you
know relevant scale
and and actually they're linked together
which actually makes sense you think
about is that because the fusion power
is the heating Source itself this means
that they're linked together and so
either makes it is projected to make
about 500 million watts of fusion power
so this is a significant amount like
this is what you would use
you know for powering cities so it's not
just the researcher they're really it is
the development of really trying to
achieve scale here so self-heating and
scale yeah yes so this this meant then
too is the the development of an
industrial base that can actually
produce the Technologies like the
electromagnets and so forth and to do it
with it is a Tokamak it is it is one of
these yes but very interesting it also
revealed limitations of of this as well
too well it is it's interesting is that
it is clearly a
um on paper and in fact in in practice
as well too the world the you know and
very different political systems and you
caught you consider at least
geopolitical or economic rivals or
whatever you want to use like working
towards a common cause and one that we
all think is Worthy is is very like okay
that's very satisfying but it's also
interesting to see the limitations of
this it's because well you've got seven
you know chefs in the kitchen
so what is this what is this meant for
in terms of the speed of the project and
the ability to to govern it and so forth
it's just been a challenge uh honestly
around us and this is I mean it's very
hard technically what's what's occurring
but when you also introduce such levels
of I mean this isn't just me saying it
there's like GAO reports from the US
government and so on this is It's hard
to like steer all of this around
um and what that's tended to do is make
it it's it's not the fastest decision
making process you know my own personal
view of it was it was it was interesting
because you asked me you said about the
magnet and Commonwealth Fusion systems
it was I worked most of my career on
eater because when I came into the field
in the early 1990s when I completed my
PhD and started to work this was one of
the most like you can't imagine being
more excited about something like we're
going to change the world with this
project we're going to do these things
and we just like Port like an entire
generation and afterwards as well too is
just poured their imagination and their
creativity about making this thing work
very good but at also at some point
though when you know when it got to
being another five years of delay or a
decade of delay you start asking
yourself well is this what I want to do
right am I going to wait for for this so
it was a part of me starting to ask
questions with my students I was like
is there another way that we can get to
this extremely worthwhile goal that
maybe maybe it's not that that maybe
it's not that pathway and the other part
that was clearly frustrating to me
because I I'm an advocate of fusion you
asked me about was I you know I was like
well it's laser Fusion or inertia or
inertial Fusion or magnetic Fusion I
just want Fusion Energy okay because I
think it's so important to the to the
world is that but the other thing if
that's the case
then why do we have only one attempt at
it on the entire planet which was either
it's like that makes no sense to me
right we should have multiple attempts
at this with different levels of
whatever you want to think about a
technical schedule scientific risk which
are Incorporated in them and that's
going to give us a better chance of
actually getting to the goal line